[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
this is the worst what they do huh where
there's a couple of guys where i go
what's up and they'll go
man you're killing it
you know don't you ever have a break
right and they start rattling things
that you're doing it's like dude we're
not yeah this is
real life here baby see when people do
that to me like do it to me like do that
right now like watch you're that guy now
what this is how i react when i go hey
dude what's going on hey andrew oh my
god davey dude killing it
and whiskey ginger man
[Laughter]
it made me so angry can you imagine if i
was here yeah yeah
let me try it yeah yeah
your way though all right yeah i get it
go ahead do you
you say hi to me in this [ __ ]
scenario
you start the thing i don't want to
start it though no you say hi and then i
because you that was
all right where are we at though
um we are oh we i'm at a guest we're
pumping at a gas station all right but
this is i'm gonna play it real okay this
is the way i would do it all right we'll
play okay for real
[Music]
just give me a second all right i'll
just play it real all right i don't
think that you would look at me like
that yes i would you would be like well
it's not me i'm playing a guy i know but
you're playing another guy but i don't
think any guy would look at me i know
how i'm playing the guy don't look at me
don't test my acting skills i know what
the guy is all right all right here we
go hold on hold on i need a second i
need a second right
so i have the thing yet right me too i'm
already here i've been already
i'm already here you just you just
started all right okay ready i'm pumping
oh [ __ ]
bob bobby i start oh
i know i [ __ ] start
sorry i start okay
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
good
hey
oh bob
hey man hey
clark hey
good to see you what's up hey dude
whoa are you killing it right yeah
bad friends yeah
magnum p.i yeah is that what you did
yeah you copied me that's what i was
just gonna do what you did yeah no why
did you copy me you said you're gonna
play it for real
play it for real oh what i would do yes
oh i didn't know i i thought you said to
do it the way you did it no you're
supposed to do it your way
[Laughter]
all right well then if we did it my way
it would we would never we would never
talk yeah yeah right all right let's
okay right
this is the way i would do it yeah
hey hey man clarky oh bob what's up man
i'll tell you what's up man you are
killing it bad friends magnum p.i i mean
you got so lister jones you're doing so
much stuff right now you're absolutely
exploding right now
you've got to be doing well that's
incredible
bad friends and tiger belly is like
murdering it's like
what zoe died
solas or jones died yeah yeah we both
did
[Laughter]
you're right here
we both that's why you don't make small
talk i don't do it i saw a dog one time
in hollywood jump out the back of a
truck when it was moving and it scared
me yeah jump right out of the back of a
truck
did it did it live yeah
i never said and stick around i had a
meeting
i used to see i used to drive by every
once in a while like a dog on the
freeway that was here and i used to feel
nothing
[Music]
not a thing because i'm the one that hit
it
let's go to a club tonight doc you want
you want to ball out i don't know gay
clubs because y'all [ __ ] why
what is that who cares what do you mean
who cares what i'm gonna do there why
can't we go to a gay club no cause you
all be doing some silly [ __ ] oh my god
this guy's so having a drink hanging out
with some dudes yeah yeah that's not my
style
what is your style my style your style
is not hanging out with human beings
human beings and [ __ ] there you go
what do you mean they're not human
beings [ __ ] gay clubs is what just
are gay dudes right yeah what do you
think is going on there yeah
nothing just all dues it's boring do you
think they're trying to force you to be
gay yeah we get it we look how we
arguing [ __ ] i don't want to be in a
[ __ ] place with a bunch of other
dudes [ __ ] out of here
having hissy fits on the [ __ ] dance
floor you do realize we're going to a
gay bar now
oh i knew this type of [ __ ] well you did
it you did this well i thought you was
gonna say no i want you to learn you got
to open your mind dude what are you
talking about i gotta open up my mind
i'm good you know i like it
it's funny andrew it's like
if you and i were at a um we're at the
abbey right in west hollywood which i've
been there yeah multiple times so
there's a club called the abbey in west
hollywood do you know what that is doc
i've heard of it yeah and so don't get
angry dude i mean if you don't own it
relax because this is set up against me
no and i'm not the bad guy but let's see
let's see how it would play out
we're not going okay
we're here welcome mademoiselle's gay
bars
hey what's up doc
what can i get you to drink
what's up you little sippy cup what's up
you little tiny drink of water how are
you doing
very well look at this little piece of
chocolate sauce i mean this is my jam
this is my jam oh i love that
twerk
i'm twerking show your [ __ ]
a little bit more delicious than that
are you coming out doc is that why
you're here you're coming i'm coming out
i'm just here with my boy
okay we're here with our boys too harry
styles watermelon sugar
watermelon sugar
watermelon sugar
okay what do you want to drink i'm a
bartender what do you want to drink i
have a pinot noir a double you want a
double yeah give him a triple a triple
piano i gotta be honest with you pinot
noir pretty gay
pretty gay pretty gay
emperors back in the day like in china
right yeah they used to have like 200
concubines no that's different though
why those are just women they got to
sleep with but you but you know these
guys have to live in a house and still
you know those concubines
how come you didn't you know i wrote you
a letter how come you didn't write me
back i mean you know everybody's so busy
i know but you know
you spent three days with dick dick and
dongdong right but me you ever see me
three more your tits are weird
the women don't look at me at all like
i'm [ __ ] invisible right you're like
i'm like you know you know what he does
he walks like 10 paces behind me when
we're walking when we come back because
you get all the looks well okay my boy
[Applause]
because he doesn't want he doesn't want
us to not he doesn't if we get
recognized yeah like if he he doesn't
like it if i get recognized and he
doesn't that hurts you it doesn't bother
me if somebody goes bobby lee and i walk
i don't give a [ __ ] he hates it when
someone goes santino and they say i
don't say anything to you he hates it
why do you hate that so much why can't
you allow him to have some fans [ __ ] it
see
i don't [ __ ] god
i don't do that [ __ ] dude you walk 10
paces behind me you know do you see you
you walk 10 paces i do but check that
out do you not like it
andrew santino you should see my face i
always go like this
so condescending i do
[Laughter]
it hurts so much there is suffering
there is there is suffering
but there's pleasure too
it's a combination of things because
there is suffering
meanwhile you call out call out bobby
lee bobby
[Laughter]
what if it's a white guy that only
recognizes him does that sting a little
bit more then
it's happened
it's happening oh it's happening dude
no yeah you know it doesn't it
you're what if it's an athlete what if
there's an athlete that recognizes him
over you like a famous [ __ ] pig
it's never happened yet well that's not
true what who who who who
no no no no i only know one last leader
yeah he only knows one and aunt donovan
and no one gives a [ __ ] about him he's a
great soccer player he's one of the best
but landon i only know landon he's the
only one yeah well you know i know
robert gronkowski yeah you do yeah
what was that tv do you think if you saw
you two he'd recognize you and not
santino
100 100 but what was the tv show it was
called game on it was like a it was so
good what was it
so there was a glory two guys
right
went to a glory hall
and one guy stuck his penis out
got his came in a random man's mouth
when they walked out together it was a
father and a son
okay right so if you did a glory hole
right and you get your dick sucked and
you walked out it was your dad
right what would you do
would you hug him dad or would you be
like what the [ __ ] or
would i hug him
is that your first dad
whenever yeah
i don't know it's your dad i wouldn't
say a word it would i would just
oh so let's let's both walk out i want
to see what you would do okay so i'm
walking out right
wait wait am i the sucky or sucker i
just you you sucked it
and you're the damn the sun okay right
so i'm zipping up oh that was the best
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
he [ __ ] did sack work
he did sack work
i walk out
dad
i think i would say dad what if he gave
me a kiss
[Laughter]
oh that'd be so good
yeah that i do that would ruin the
family right okay what about this okay
what if you saw
you know i love these scenarios well
yeah like what okay all right what what
what if you're at like a a butt plug
convention
[Music]
and they're like you know try out some
of the newest butt plugs the newest anal
beads right and and they're like dude
you someone comes dude you got to see
this guy he's got 40 [ __ ] beads in
his ass and they get bigger as they go
and if you said that to me i'd be like
where we gotta go we gotta go and you're
like they're pulling out now it's like a
[ __ ] chainsaw right and there's a
dude like a you pulling it up
there's such a big crowd we have to get
in excuse me excuse me excuse me
and everybody's screaming more more more
more
you can't believe it right and then this
guy gets up and it's your father
killing it no no i would be like you
know what i would do huh honestly i
would so i'd be in the front of the
crowd right i would slowly just
backwards
the homer simpson yeah absoria would
absorb me back right and i'd probably
walk they'll be the loneliest parking
lot walk into your car because
everyone's gonna come up to you did you
see the anal bead guys yeah yeah it was
amazing what i would do i would kick
something just kick it
just like a tin can just one loose anal
bead that fell off a rope you just kick
it down there right what if you saw your
family at a sex convention type of thing
i think i'd feel
pride
would do gay porn if a car like how much
oh dude how much [ __ ] a million to shoot
you would pay a million dollars just to
do it yeah
[Laughter]
no no
[Laughter]
i googled it that's how it cost how much
it costs
a million dollars forget it yeah
right right oh it's like a membership
it's like
yeah any referrals yeah yeah you
wouldn't you would never do gay porn no
for a million dollars a shoot i would no
you wouldn't i would do it 40 in a row
40 days in a row my [ __ ] would be
[ __ ] grisly and open right yeah but i
would just be like i'm gonna i would go
to nevada get up ranch and heal up for
the rest of my life that's a good idea
so funny just to see like a little
chained up dumpling and everyone just
comes in and just annihilates your
[ __ ]
you just have just like
your legs and your arms just rope to the
wall like yeah yeah there's comments is
dick is pixelated just one pixel
no i'd have that same andrew sent you a
link
a million a million
million is the
yeah don't you have a million how much
do you have left like
you feel like you're stressing me out
you're stressing me out what do you mean
how much do you have left how much did
she leave with
we weren't married again we weren't
married during the process and there's
no common law thing in in california no
but like yeah there literally is comment
that literally is coming not in
california look it up they're 100 as
common law in california google it
google it right now somebody google it
mark has a computer that you're
insulting
the funny thing is it is it is
it's not it is google it it's not and
what are you gonna do if i win if i win
oh what do you want if you want a
million dollars i want you to poke my
dick 10 times in a row there is no
common-law marriage in california
no chance there isn't what does it say
does not recognize common-law marriage
even though california does not have
common-law marriages unmarried people
have been together for an extended
period of time do you still get some
right yes right there is right there's
laws that protect you no can i tell you
what those rights are yes that's only in
situations where let's suppose i was
paying mortgage she's paying my mortgage
with me yeah then she has more rights
but i pay the mortgage shelter
yeah yeah
you know he's looked this up yeah yeah
you know he got scared
[Applause]
that's a clip for the [ __ ] internet
you guys don't know each other but i
know both of you so i'd like to nominate
that i'm there when are we doing some
shroomies can't wait for that see this
is great and you can we'll tape it and
you'll see it yeah you can watch it by
yourself later
you know what it feels like what is it
stop asian hate
that's what it feels like yeah we're six
months ago this show is stopping asian
hey yeah yeah yeah yeah no no we've
stopped it because of this show you're
doing agent hey i'm stopping it oh i'm
doing asian hate all three of you are in
what way what interesting you're you're
excluding me from activities how by
saying that i have to watch the tape of
you guys partying you're sober
we gave you a trophy when you kicked the
habit yeah i said i was willing to
relapse to do the [ __ ] thing man this
says bobby lee kick the habit 2022 it's
done you're sober now tell me more let
me tell you something chad hey you hey
youtube bad friends let me be your good
friend to let you know here you're both
right see okay because we're both right
andrew's right because he gave you a
nice trophy he didn't want you to kick
the habit and i'll sit here and tell you
on behalf of the vegan sitting next to
me shroomies just mushrooms not gonna
hurt you it's not a drug come on yeah
you can come with us you can come with
us okay i would never want to drag
somebody back into this [ __ ] though if
you're like legitimately let me make
them do it
if i retire i'll probably die you you're
the same way
you love work
i just need to be doing it yeah you need
to do something yeah i can't imagine if
they were like oh you have throat cancer
mr lee you have throat cancer god i hope
not holy [ __ ] right and you can't talk
ever again oh and then what would you do
just program your joke
right who couldn't talk but he was a
stand-up yeah but all his jokes were in
the thing did they crush
they did my point is that your dad could
have [ __ ] programmed no
no that's what you think he's writing it
because does his facial expressions
match up to the thing no it's like look
at the size of the tits on this [ __ ] in
the front row but he's not moving his
lips oh
look at the size of it no
i was trying to do that
but you're moving your [ __ ] lips well
i'm not a [ __ ] ventriloquist bob
welcome back to the channel i hope
you're enjoying this video so far we
need to take a quick 90 second break to
hear a word from our friends at the
freeze pipe but after that stick around
for some more of bad friends funniest
moments
[Music]
all right so if you've been in this
space for a while you probably already
know what this is if not this is called
a freeze bomber right it's from a
company called freeze pipe now everyone
knows the most common way to cool your
hits is to actually just put ice cubes
in whatever piece you have basically
freeze pipe just said let's make that
into a simplified version less of a
hassle more convenient and more
efficient and that's basically what we
have here today this little intricate
piece right here in front of me
alright guys so as you can see there is
a glycerin chamber you can see the
glycerin making its little bubbles up
what the glycerin does it's going to
cool your hit so the smoke is
transferred from the pipe through the
little coils
down until here where you get to hit it
grease pipe of course has freezable
pipes freezable rigs they got bubblers
they got different size bongs anything
they get smoked out of they have it on
the website oh my gosh this thing's so
badass when you hit it you literally
feel the smoke getting cooled into your
lungs so it provides a super nice hit
that was awesome pipe with glycerin
inside of it freeze it for an hour ice
cold hits honestly that was cold and
smooth as [ __ ] i seriously think this is
the only rig i've ever taken a dab out
of and never coughed where's the freeze
pipe bring me that damn freeze pipe i'm
sick and the only cure is to bring me my
freeze pipe
you know korean's [ __ ] up before that
you know that right hey uh i've lost his
mic who's because because you keep
[ __ ] moving around
cause you won't sit still for five
[ __ ] seconds
sound guy you gotta get a new sound guy
unprofessional sound like that
he
[Laughter]
i love them you know it's just jokes
comedy bro
yeah i didn't
that's gonna happen three more times 100
like nine minutes no doubt in my mind
that it's gonna happen again okay i'll
sit still like this good luck can you
hear me now dude well he's not back
there yet
go back to your station dude
testing testing
what's your name i want to call you dude
because i'm going to call you dude
[Laughter]
can i let me tell you something bobby
the look in his eye is bobby's underwear
inside out he [ __ ] hates you i know
he doesn't it's his second day on it
probably oh do you hate me dude look at
his face always stops us oh [ __ ] look at
his [ __ ] face he's livid you know
what you knew wants to say he wants to
know he wants to say charlie yeah like
we're attacking him
like a nom remember nam why are you
saying we
yeah you're attacking him and you're
charlie you're korean try that again try
it again
clean in get a clean tape
dude what was up with his face santino
do you know something about his face the
[ __ ] was that what was on his face what
do you think he was thinking dude yeah
he thought uh
he he's mitch mcconnell and i'm his wife
god damn dude what the [ __ ]
yeah yeah i don't know what the [ __ ]
look dude that's what i got about before
political takes that's right like that
yeah yeah switch it up like that bro
that was cool i think go back to [ __ ]
rodney king let's go let's try that yeah
let's try that one rodney king let's go
back to that
no this is what irritated me all right
go ahead so now i'm playing war zone
with some of the guys
right mm-hmm and they're they're playing
they're on twitch
and um one of the guys i'll just say his
name raymie yeah you know your boy my
boy yeah
hey um hey bob
you have a problem with eric is that how
he talks yeah that's the way he sounds
to me i go i don't have a problem with
him
i love him he goes well some of the fans
are saying that he's complaining that
our their friendship is over no
friendship is over first of all that's
not true i know but that's what the
[ __ ] people said on the [ __ ] okay
session but by the way i'm not gonna say
anything more i'm gonna let you finish
because i'm gonna need the floor all
right all right so go ahead all right
fine he's gonna filibuster
yeah right i'm just gonna let you know
when he did this i realized that all the
weight
lost from his body but not his knuckles
he's got hairy ugly [ __ ] knuckles
and look at the hair pushed up on his
wrist you can't just make fun of him the
whole time you have to explain your side
of the story because he's going to get
his head out he's really irritating me
right now his knuckles are irritating
did you look like me
fat dog tennis playing panda right now
that's what you look like all right
too
enough
enough it looks like bobby goes home and
he takes his hair off like
this that's funny what a day i've had
you know whatever you think mr potato
head
i'm talking about putting things on you
know you look like mr potatoes go on
with your [ __ ] store
so don't [ __ ] tell me about
detachments
all right there we go here's how you win
on america's got talent get hit by
something a bus a car a sad story yeah
or a kid or some sort of disability
somebody if you have all three you won
the whole thing you don't have to do
anything cancer yes that's a huge one
somebody has to have cancer either you
or someone you love
right right you have a disability yeah
and you came from a tough place yeah
bum-bum-bum but if i'll win you know
what i'm gonna do
i'm going to go to a rooftop right douse
myself right in what you know with with
um gasoline oh good yeah i think that's
implied with dallas like nobody else
well i get on a rooftop by putting on
sunscreen yeah two different guys i'm
gonna light myself on fire then jump off
break every bone in my body i'm gonna
have a couple of guys put water on me
right right and i'm gonna show up
right
on america's got talent and i'm gonna
go
and i'm going to get the golden buzzer
i'm going to win the whole thing really
you think that's going to work
can you imagine that they wheeling a guy
immediately after you yeah who's like oh
look he's an asian guy who also set on
fire and fell off a roof yeah but he's
gay and then he wins just
right yeah
beat you by one he probably one thing
yeah right you think backstage you they
see the minorities like how deformed
they are and they're like oh that's
gonna be tough to be
like i just have no arms this guy's
burned and he has no legs yeah that
guy's on fire right now
so we're judges right this is this is
called um los angeles got something
ellie got something yeah ellie got
something right and we're both dressed
as my name is simon chow and you're
simon
no if you're simon chow yeah i have to
be you know
heidi wong heidi wong
wong we're both you have accents you
better believe it
hey welcome to
america la got something
right there welcome to l.a got something
this is i'm simon chao
i'm heidi wong yeah
anyway tell your story what your story
what first of all what's your talent i
am i like to sing
oh
another singer
what a big deal big deal yeah so what
what
so tell me about yourself
i i'm from um afghanistan
oh
bad bad place that's weirdly bad really
bad
uh poppy seeds that make heroin
what i
and i try to deflect but he blew up and
he's not here anymore
nick cannon is like oh hit this
[ __ ] in
interesting so you know but i remember
last year we had another guy from
afghanistan his missile hit him
my brother stepped on the ied other
brother
um
[Laughter]
junkyard and machete in junkyard
it killed people it's like my mother in
her your brother
no mommy anymore
well that will happen if there was a
machete
around it yeah okay for us now
i'm very nervous
yeah here we go it's probably not good
come on
yeah
that would be your freedom that would be
your freedom yeah and you and you would
go far far far so far i have a residency
in vegas yeah yeah yeah yeah and they'd
have like photoshop pictures of my
mother
machete
like this is dedicated to my mouth
as you walk into the hallway to the
showroom it's got your brother blown up
yeah they'll be inside i do a psa like
everybody watch where you walk thank you
good night
yeah i'm gonna get it anyway i'm not
gonna support it not gonna support it
not gonna support it yeah if i relapse
andrew
andy schultz yes if i relapse what do
you think dude he got mad at me how do
you get mad so mad at me for not giving
him like what do you think love is this
is what addiction is that why you stayed
in that relationship
dude
[Laughter]
i love you that's what you [ __ ]
texted me you [ __ ] dude
you got up like a transformer dude
[Laughter]
wrong
[Laughter]
where is he looking
it is
so proof is in the pudding that i did
the right thing in mexico
yes dude
you know why this whole kick started he
got into a fight with him yelled at me
yelled at me for not getting
bobby's the only transformer that's more
dangerous as a car though
[Laughter]
dude
that's gonna be funny dude
she um has a thing with me is that um
and
it it'll it may never work out our
relationship may never work out
i have to say that and that's real
but she's going to college you guys
aren't working out six months
and i'll tell you why right
is she doesn't she has a thing where
she doesn't come to me with any problems
i'll come in the kitchen and she'll just
this is what she does i'll walk in the
kitchen
and let's say she's standing right here
as soon as i walk she'll just go around
the counter
to avoid you to avoid me yeah but also
to be fair to her you can be very
volatile at times
am i ever volatile i just let it out go
ahead like you explain where i go
like far away when you come in in the
kitchen it's because you always want to
punch me you want to punch her oh god
she's so silly
you [ __ ] know
you [ __ ] rat time out was the story
with the girl with the black eye was
that rudy
wait a minute what is he where does he
punch you let her talk where does he
punch you where yeah like on the arm or
in the stomach or on the what does he do
arm he hits you on the on the arm hard
sometimes hard she's almost like she's a
tiny little girl i do it as a joke yeah
oh you hit women as a joke
no
playful
in a playful way oh oh it's funny
thank you for watching try not to laugh
bad friends edition and if you'd like to
join the fastest growing comedy
community in the world be sure to
subscribe to joke world follow us on
instagram for some more content from
your favorite comedians
[Music]
you